any reception was always going to be
warmer than this the one for Scotland's
first Minister Nicholas sturgeon
the new kid again met by cheering crowds
the celebrations were to Mark dunk
firmly in becoming a city as part of the
Queen's Platinum Jubilee her Legacy as
her son acknowledged never far away
there could be no more fitting way to
mark my beloved mothers extraordinary
life of service than by granting this
honor to a place made famous
by its own long and distinguished
history in the birthplace of Charles the
first Charles III knows it's now his
turn to make new Royal connections
[Laughter]
in their hundreds this was always bound
to be a friendly crowd the ongoing
respect for the queen helping him along
whoever came out to see him I think
he'll do really well
um he's such a good teacher she's a big
this visit including a stop at the
city's Abby was always in the diary
their team are now having to work out
what they both can and can't do in their
new roles Colin Bruce from the group
potty plus was impressed by how much
Camilla understood I think they're very
aware of the social issues around the
country at the moment and I feel that
they are genuinely engaged with it so I
I am very hopeful of the future a
slightly younger Monarch does mean that
we are going to see him doing more of
this and with that comes opportunities a
chance for people to really get to know
the new king but also added scrutiny for
everything he does and says
respecting Britain's diversity is one
commitment that he's already made in
Edinburgh they'd invited South Asian
communities to Hollywood house these
weeks are important for building new
relationships and as his mother would
have taught him a sense of shared
history and friendship will always go a
long way Brianna Mills Sky News in
Dunford